[Music]
in case you haven't looked at your list
of attendees I want to let you know that
with the possible exception of 1926 we
have at least one person here from every
single class since 1923
I think that's truly remarkable and I
want to congratulate you all we have a
very full schedule this morning so I
want to get off to a rapid start and
we'll begin with opening remarks by John
Deutsch who's Provost of the Institute
John's professional career has been
primarily associated with the Department
of Chemistry and other endeavors but the
reality is he started things off with a
bachelor's degree from our department
and I think his heart is still there
John
thank you very much mark
well I considered a great privilege to
have the opportunity to open this
conference on behalf of the Institute
it's a privilege to participate in this
centennial celebration and I'm pleased
that I've been allocated a few minutes
just two or three beyond the normal
cameo appearance expected of a Provost
to actually share some thoughts about
this centennial celebration this
department has made remarkable
contributions to the nation to the
economy of this nation both in peacetime
and in wartime my own personal earliest
recollections of my father who was an
engineer talking with Eadie Gilliland
and with Bradley Dooley about the
problems of synthetic rubber in the
Second World War in the early 40s the
mid 40s
from that period before that period to
the present time this department has
been important to the country it has
also been exceptionally important to the
Institute and finally it really has been
exceptionally important to me personally
the faculty in this department had a
very pronounced effect on my education
the way I think and I'm of course like
very many other people in this audience
extraordinarily grateful for that well
with essentially of accomplishment
behind it and there has been just an
enormous number of people who've made
great contributions to the department to
permit that century of accomplishment I
know
the most recent contributions of Jimmy
way to leadership of the department to
strengthen it and making it an even more
important unit at MIT it is very
appropriate to think about the
challenges of the future it's perhaps
even
especially important because I believe
along with many others and I know you'll
be hearing from Ralph Landau about this
later today that this nation really does
face some very significant problems with
respect to its Science and Technology
activities and with respect to its
record in economic productivity and it
is extremely seems to be pertinent and
correct that under such circumstances
where the nation does face I will use
the word crisis in its economic affairs
in terms of the votes long term
industrial productivity and economic
competitiveness it seems to me entirely
appropriate that this department which
has done so much raises its head and
says which directions should we continue
to go in in pursuing that record of
accomplishments it is also a subject
what we should do for the nation for the
nation's economy more generally for the
world that is being broadly discussed
within the MIT School of Engineering and
indeed throughout the Institute and in
that regard also it's appropriate for
this department to look at the
challenges ahead I would like to just
mention to you five questions that I
think are important to keep in mind as
one thinks about the next century of
chemical engineering at MIT and in the
country the first of these questions has
to do with the role of chemical
engineering in manufacturing and in
process industries my judgment chemical
engineering contrast to many of the
other engineering disciplines has a much
more impressive record of performance
that its ability to deal with the
practicing industry and with especially
manufacturing and processing within the
practical chemical industry but we do
have to consider it seems to me again
how we are going to deal with that in
our educational curriculum here at the
Institute and I would be so bold as to
suggest that the approach which is used
in this department of chemical
engineering including its practice
school
history might be used as a model for
other areas of engineering as well
secondly I believe that we have
important number of new technologies
emerging in this nation well known to
all of you here today I speak especially
biotechnology micro electronics
materials processing these are new areas
compared to the historical subjects of
petrochemicals in plastics if you like
of chemical engineering and I think it
is very important that we worry as
chemical engineers how our educational
efforts will be designed to make the
contributions to these new areas
biotechnology and micro electronics
materials that it did to its historical
areas in the past 1/3 I am struck
because of some of my own personal
background about some of the importance
to industry of international questions
of questions of energy availability of
questions to environmental impact and I
think that we still have some very major
questions about how these these issues
the international context of business
energy and the environment should be
integrated into the considerations of
the chemical engineering education both
at the graduate and undergraduate level
finally I am interested especially
because as mentioned I am a chemistry
professor not a chemical engineering
professor the interaction between
chemical engineering and the fundamental
sciences it's a very important subject
how do we introduce chemical engineers
to the fundamentals of chemistry physics
and of course now in a much more
important and interesting way modern
biology these are all important
questions that I hope will be dealt with
in our thoughts and perhaps even in the
comments during this convocation as I
say all of this is to be accomplished in
the next century these exciting
challenges while maintaining
excellence and while maintaining a
central focus of the discipline we have
an enormous diversity a welcomed
diversity within the practice of
Chemical Engineering and its scholarly
attributes in my judgment it has been
one of the really magnificent
accomplishments of the intellectual
world of the United States of science
and technology the past century and I'm
confident that it will be so during the
next century as well thank you very much
[Applause]
our next speaker known to his colleagues
as skip Scriven is a distinguished
scholar from the University of Minnesota
and this year he was the Warren K Lewis
lecturer in the department just a few
days ago we were treated to a marvelous
lecture on his recent research which I
think in the future will be looked back
at as a landmark in the development of
chemical engineering today however he
himself is going to look back and tell
us about his views of the early
intellectual development of our
discipline
good morning I want to report that I've
been a student of chemical engineering
at the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology since I was an undergraduate
in Berkeley and nearby shale development
and a much more acute student since
joining the department's visiting
committee some nine years ago that adds
to my pleasure in participating in this
convocation and sharing with you some
views of our disciplines early evolution
the announced title modified just now by
Clark I notice but what you see printed
is not fully accurate but the best that
he and I could come up with some months
ago I should add that we plan to
collaborate in this endeavor until he
was overtaken by the planning for not
only this convocation but also the
marvelous academic symposium hosted by
the faculty these past two days
but Clark did find a few hours now and
again to be my sounding board and I want
to express my appreciation of those very
stimulating sessions my first point this
morning is a reminder that chemical
technologies are dynamic as are all
others their rates of evolution wax and
wane but there is a pattern we have the
first slide please
my diagram derives from one by William
Abernathy and Philip Townsend an
electrical engineer and an economist
chemical engineer both turned doctors of
Business Administration in their 1975
article in technology productivity on
technology productivity and process
change in which they analyzed what they
called the life cycle of a technology or
industry which seems to me a pattern of
evolution successive processing
technologies spring variously from
scientific discovery and technological
invention they're developed and
commercialized which many call
innovation that is they rise they
flourish and they diffuse to other
owners and to other nations gaining
broader application and generating
greater competition and lessened
profitability then they subside into the
industrial background of mature
technologies or they may be displaced by
newly emerging processes or products
some persist perhaps metamorphosed some
disappear that all evolved slide off
please
the first chemical manufacturers to be
in of
in the modern sense where the Chamber
process for sulfuric acid in the mid
18th century in England and the LeBlanc
process for sodium carbonate which
originated in France around the turn of
that century and soon diffused to
England and throughout the continent
both stimulated other technological
developments some stemming from what
would today be called their
environmental impacts both through
competition the one from vapor phase
catalytic processes for sulfuric acid
but not until those were commercialized
on 50 or 60 years later which finally
replaced the chamber process in the
early 20th century by and large the
other from the marvelously inventive
Solvay process which more rapidly
replaced the early LeBlanc technology
both of these newer technologies heavily
metamorphosed are in the industrial
background today chemical engineers at
large pay them little heed though annual
US production of sodium carbonate is
about 10 million tonnes divided between
the Solvay process still and mining at
trona sulfuric acid is of course an
equally basic commodity chemical Solvay
is 1872 ammonia soda process was a
breakthrough he broke it up into
separate operations of gas liquid
contacting reaction with cooling and
separations he invented new types of
equipment for carrying them all out
continuously
on a large scale and he himself dealt
with the chemistry the materials
handling the process engineering and the
equipment design in short he performed
as what would come to be called a
chemical engineer though that was not
evident to his contemporaries that
surely impressed the aggressive
Americans who soon license the process
and integrated into a fast developing
inorganic chemicals industry that would
be invading European markets around the
turn of the century 1900 and these two
heavy chemical lines are the roots of
Chemical Engineering they brought the
need for chemists and engineers and
chemical manufacture they also gave rise
to George Davis English industrial
entrepreneur who in 1880 turned
Environmental Protection Act and for sir
hydrochloric acid contamination of the
British Midlands countryside by 1882 he
was calling publicly for chemical
engineering and a society to
institutionalize it
the society which he helped to found
chose instead to be called the Society
of chemical industry then in 1887
George Davis became some sort of adjunct
professor in Manchester and gave a
course of published lectures on his new
subject and finally in 1901 he turned
these into the first book on the
discipline of chemical engineering and I
have the slide second slide please his
preface highlighted the mounting
competition from America and heavy
chemicals as the Britisher writing and
as he put it the wonderful developments
in Germany of commercial organic
chemistry an expanded two volumes second
edition was published in 1904 and it is
pictured here you see the radical
departure from the earlier textbooks and
handbooks on industrial chemistry which
covered each chemical industry
separately Davis had recognized that the
basic problems were engineering problems
and that the principles for dealing with
them could be organized around basic
operations common to many fluid flow if
you look closely solids treating heat or
cold transfer extraction absorption
distillation and so on as WK Louis noted
much later the concept was developed
here in this book as quantitatively as
the resources of the 1880s had allowed
not very quantitatively unfortunately
very few people were ready to act on
George Davis's vision of a discipline of
chemical engineering either in 1887 or
in 1901 it fit no university curriculum
of that time but it did not go unnoticed
in the United States where there were
those who called themselves chemical
engineers and a university curriculum
called Chemical Engineering I have that
slide off please
the next chemical manufacturers to be
innovated were batch processes for small
volume production high value-added dyes
and other coal-tar derivatives beginning
with Perkins mauve or indigo in England
but very soon dominated by German
research prowess in in organic chemistry
and it's successful integration into an
industrial juggernaut that soon
controlled international markets early
pharmaceuticals followed the same route
here though the research chemists
laboratory methods were turned over to a
mechanical engineer to scale
directly there was no Harbor though in
this there was no harbinger of chemical
engineering nor did it lead the way to
continuous processing in the economies
that that could bring when markets
expanded and competition demanded
meanwhile the sugar industry's sugar
beet sugar cane distillation industries
and many others were evolving in Europe
process engineering and industrial
chemistry curricula were being installed
in the new technical universities the
second shift surely that it appeared in
Germany Switzerland to Austria and even
hungry a few of the professors and their
counterparts chief engineers and certain
companies highly educated in science and
mathematics took to analyzing common
constituent operations like heat
transfer by Peck clay in France
vaporization condensation and drying by
house brunt in Germany distillation by
house Brandt and by Sorel and France
monographs on all of these subjects were
published by these authors between 1880
and 1899 these two were important for
runners of chemical engineering electro
chemical processing rose in England
Germany and France in the decades before
1900 but it diffused to America where
cheap electricity generated from cheap
coal at first and mass production in the
new tradition of iron steel copper
nickel and tin enabled the Americans to
compete successfully even invading
international markets for example with
electrolytic caustic soda and chlorine
two of the items that bothered George
Davis in that preface erode the United
States Charles Hall invented in 1886 the
most successful process for producing
aluminum and there were many other such
developments in 1895 came the
hydroelectric development of Niagara
Falls and by 1910 that was the location
of and I quote the world's greatest
center of electrochemical activity and
not only of production but also of
process research and product development
outstanding was Fred Frederick Beckett
and his Niagara research laboratories
where he invented processes for making
carbon free chromium tungsten molybdenum
and vanadium by direct reduction of
their oxides and other important
processes as well this was one of the
very first industrial research labs in
America
and it and Beckett were soon bought up
by the Union Carbide to be there's
there's something else about Beckett he
was educated as an electrical engineer
when he got into the electrochemical
processing area he went back to school
at Columbia University to get physical
chemistry and industrial chemistry he
earned an MS in 1899 and all but
completed a PhD in electrochemistry in
1902 several years before he went to
Niagara electrochemistry at that time
was the glamour science and the emerging
technology the electrochemical Society
was the meeting ground for leaders of
the new science of physical chemistry
like Ostwald
Nernst Bancroft of Cornell Whitney who
moved from MIT to Schenectady to head
General Electric's brand-new research
laboratory the country's first corporate
research establishment the Society is
the meeting ground for the leading
electrical electrical chemical engineers
like Steinmetz of GE Tesla the
independent Burgess of University of
Wisconsin and Burgess battery for
educated inventor entrepreneurs like
Elmer Sperry then of national battery
later of gyroscope fame and Herbert Dow
of Midland and for prominent industrial
chemists and chemical engineers like
Samuel Sadler of Philadelphia William
Walker of the partnership of little and
Walker in Boston and Fritz Haber of the
Karlsruhe Technical University in
Germany as a matter of fact all of these
save Sperry Dow and Sattler presented
papers at the semiannual meetings of the
newly formed American Electric Chemical
Society in 1902 1903 and 1904 with the
mention of William Walker let's go back
to the 1880s and the scene then in
America's colleges and universities
industrialization of the country was
accelerated and with it the need for
engineers and to a lesser extent
chemists from decades earlier there was
popular demand for a relevant college
education and this had been answered by
the appearance of engineering schools
like Rensselaer first of all Brooklyn
Polytechnic and MIT also scientific
schools at Yale Harvard Dartmouth
Columbia and so on and more importantly
I think by the Morrill Act of 1862
which enabled the states to establish
land-grant colleges by the 1880s there
were strong curricula and science and
engineering that had sprung up in many
of these among them the Pennsylvania
State College there a young William
Walker enrolled in 1886 and graduated in
chemistry in 1890 having been a good
student he set off for graduate study in
Germany as did some 1000 other top
graduates in chemistry between 1850 and
World War one and perhaps nine thousand
more in other fields Germany was then
the center of freedom of learning
freedom of teaching academic research
and chemistry returning from girding on
with a PhD in 1892 Walker taught a
couple years at Penn State moved to MIT
then resigned in 1900 to join MIT
chemistry graduate Arthur little in a
consulting industrial chemistry
partnership little by the way had lost
his original partner Griffin in a
laboratory explosion at MIT has at many
other schools individual courses and
laboratories in industrial chemistry
largely descriptions of the manufacture
of diverse chemicals were being taught
in the 1880s the teacher at MIT was
Lewis Norton an MIT graduate and an 1879
girding and PhD in chemistry he'd been a
textile mill chemist several years and
had come to appreciate engineering
problems of not only and I quote him the
textile industry but also a furnace
construction and regulation and of the
manufacture of organic products impel he
wrote by a demand for engineers skilled
in chemistry in 1888 he proposed a new
curriculum course ten to be mainly the
mechanical engineering curriculum but
with industrial chemistry courses and
laboratory in the third year
Norton lined up professor Peabody to
teach a special course on and again I
quote chemical machinery from an
engineering point of view pumps
refrigerating machinery filter presses
and methods for evaporation and vacuo
and Norton himself began developing a
companion fourth-year course he called
applied chemistry
the name norton chose for the new
curriculum 1888 was chemical engineering
though the curriculum itself contained
no course called chemical engineering
and was taught by no one called a
chemical engineer the proposal was
approved by the faculty and by the
corporation eleven sophomores were
dragooned or somehow enrolled in the new
curriculum and they embarked on it
exactly 100 years ago and so here we are
today Louis Norton died less than two
years later at age 38 I think it was and
the curriculum reverted to mechanical
engineering plus industrial chemistry
the combination that began to be called
Chemical Engineering elsewhere the
University of Pennsylvania being next in
1892 so begins an acorn to growth Arthur
little may later have said may have the
next slide please
coming back to 1902 in that year William
Walker not only became a charter member
of the American electrochemical Society
he also accepted an appointment in the
chemistry department at MIT to head
course 10 though he continued his
partnership with Arthur little until
1905 to his new position he brought his
recollections of Norton's ideas his own
annotated copy of George Davis's book on
chemical engineering and principles he
had in mind for transforming the
chemical engineering curriculum from
what happened it's plain that his
program was to incorporate the new
sciences of physical chemistry and
thermodynamics the new engineering
sciences we would say today of heat
transfer distillation evaporation and
fluid mechanics that had emerged in
Europe to organize a chemical
engineering course including
laboratories around Davis's conception
of what would come to be known as the
unit operations and also to develop
research through student theses and
industrial interactions now the next
slide please the success of walker's
program was assured when he arranged in
1904 1905 graduate warren lewis to go to
germany for a PhD in chemistry at
Breslau for upon returning in 1908 lewis
joined in and embarked on a series of
analyses published analyses of
distillation filtration fluid
counter-current contacting heat-transfer
and so on most of them involving
bachelors and masters theses these
researches develop principles of
Chemical Engineering which were
expounded in mimeograph notes for
classes and then the famous 1923 book by
Walker Lewis and the younger McAdams who
had joined them in 1919 the first
textbook and a fine one and of course
shaped the discipline and helped define
the profession now the next slide please
walker's program was further reinforced
by his former partner Arthur D little in
1908 they took part in a meeting in
Philadelphia to organize an American
Institute of chemical engineers against
the decided opposition of the American
Chemical Society incidentally it appears
that no one with a degree in chemical
engineering was among the industrial
chemists and mechanical engineers who
founded the AIChE Walker himself delayed
joining until well after he'd been
president of the electrochemical Society
in 1911 little until he was 20 of the
ACS 1913 1914 anyway from 1908 little
took increasing interest in chemical
engineering education by 1915 as
chairman of a visiting committee in that
year's report little recommended
establishing a school of chemical
engineering practice which was duly
started the next year with George East's
Eastman's endowment I think was $300,000
in the same 1915 report little famous is
a fine speaker and writer particularly
on the need for Industrial Research in
America coined a name that stuck it was
unit operations for those basic physical
physical operations in chemical
manufacturer that Davis had written
about decades earlier what none of them
got around to identifying Davis Walker
Lewis or little were the basic kinds of
chemical operations in chemical
manufacture but there's not time for
that story nor is there for the story of
how little led the later stages of the a
I see a cheese 12-year effort which
ultimately succeeded to define chemical
Engineering prescribed the basic
curriculum and established a national
accrediting scheme the first in
engineering I have a slide off please
the transformation Walker and his
associates worked at MIT was abundantly
successful though not without stress and
strain over chemistry and chemical
engineering and one in the same
department and over the role of contract
research in a university so it is at any
rate that Walker is widely recognized
Department which split from chemistry in
1920 and was headed by Warren Lewis as
the center of early development
testimony to the success were the
impacts of its graduates ideas
approaches and research results on the
chemical and petroleum industries of the
United States which had come out of
World War one the world's number one
economic power in the decades before the
war Narron stand Harbor and others in
Germany had taken up gas phase reactions
and were soon pursuing nitrogen fixation
by ammonia by ammonia synthesis a goal
of tremendous economic and geopolitical
significance and recognized in other
countries as well Babur got the
breakthrough by discovering a catalyst
in 1908
bhadiya aniline and soda fabric BASF
took on the development assigning to it
a self-made chemical engineer Carl Bosch
he was a mechanical engineering graduate
of Leipzig University with a PhD in
industrial chemistry he he worked with
Alvin
Natacha chemist who oversaw 20,000
trials with different catalyst
formulations to find the best Bosch
designed the first high-pressure
continuous flow tubular reactor actually
a two bundle and the rest of the plant
in 1913 they had the haber-bosch process
for synthetic ammonia in operation and
patented a signal accomplishment like
solve a's after the war german
technology was a war prize and in
America in the 1920s process innovation
turned to high pressure and often higher
temperature processes capitalizing on
German
chances in vapor phase catalytic
reaction processes the first products
were synthetic methanol and other
commercial solvents setting the stage
for the coming era of chemicals from
petroleum feedstocks now looked upon as
the tradition in chemical engineering
the the feedstocks were in particular
the refinery off gases which were being
burned as fuel rising amounts of
ethylene and other olefins among them
more and more petroleum was being
thermally cracked to increase gasoline
yield and olefins were a byproduct this
large and expanding area of opportunity
for chemical engineering was
overshadowed by petroleum refining
itself which had developed out of the
mainstream of chemical processing
thermal cracking a crude kind of
reaction processing had been innovated
by Standard Oil in 1912 catalytic
cracking was a couple decades in the
future distillation separations
incredible as it may seem today were a
batch process in refineries until in the
post-war years continuous flow pipe
Stills and fractionators came in
abruptly there was a high demand for
analysis and design of distillation
equipment I have the next slide please
Clark Robinson of MIT who had graduated
in 1909 spent five years in industry and
returned to a masters and joined the
staff obliged in 1922 with the first
physical chemistry based text on the
elements of fractional distillation it
was a best-seller relatively speaking
what if I remarkable is that in the same
year Robinson also published a book on
the recovery of volatile solvents and
the next year he co-authored a seminal
little book some a little textbook with
Professor Hitchcock of the mathematics
department may have an active slide
please
a remarkable outburst of book
publication here's the little book
differential equations in applied
chemistry it's been unsung for years
though it went into a second edition in
1936 the preface acknowledges the
goading of Warren Lewis in constructing
the book I highlight it because I
recently learned that this little book
sitting in the library
of a state university in the southern
portion of the United States was the
inspiration of a of Bob Pickford who
became a prominent chemical engineer how
difficult it is to know when such events
take take place that set careers in in
motion may I have this that slide off
please I like to skip the next two
slides I'll have to close off the story
without getting into how unit operations
research sprung up in other places and
the center of mass shifted by the late
20s to tom Chilton's famous group of
chemical engineers in du Pont's
experimental station but I shouldn't
leave these views of early evolution
with you without making a point in the
early 30s one of Chilton's people from
MIT John Perry led the construction of
our chemical engineers handbook it was a
compilation of the best and the most
useful of American Chemical Engineering
it happens at the same time in Germany
by cohn Jakob and harbor were editing a
multi author multi volume German Hahn
book dare Kimmy and jr. may I have the
next slide please
here they are Perry's handbook in front
the haand book lining the the table in
the back you can count the number of
volumes my point is that although the
discipline and the profession of
chemical engineering had been born and
grown up in the United States still in
the 30s there was greater a greater
repository of expertise and knowledge
especially science-based knowledge in
the German chemical industry in
universities one can question why there
was not more assimilation on this side
of the Atlantic of reactor design for
instance Boyken Jakob in harbor in first
volume the first part of the first
volume there and their preface
acknowledged their great debt to the
concepts of Walker Lewis and McAdams in
the book of 10 years
let me sum this up with a view of the
name changes of the magazine that
started out may have the next slide
please the magazine that started out
electrochemical industry on the left in
that's the year the electrochemical
Society was founded it went through
changes electrochemical in metallurgical
industry metallurgical and chemical
engineering and by 1918 it was chemical
and metallurgical engineering and so it
remained until 1946 when it became just
Chemical Engineering if you look very
closely there's something about
metallurgical engineering under the
masthead
I had to slide off in closing I want to
say that in my sporadic rummaging
through the literature nowhere have I
found described what is surely an
interesting subject worthy of being
developed by scholars of engineering and
technology
what makes an engineering discipline
like Chemical Engineering and what
maintains the Associated profession how
does it depend on the industry served
and the way their technologies evolve
and chemical technologies most certainly
do go through life cycles how does it
depend on neighboring disciplines like
chemistry electrochemistry metallurgy
and now material science in the
competition amongst them how does it
depend on publication of textbooks
handbooks professional journals and
research journals how does it depend
upon university curricula and
accrediting bodies on University
Department structure on its relation to
source science like chemistry how does
it depend on the professional society or
contending professional societies as in
the case of chemical engineering and no
doubt most important of all for an
engineering discipline how does it
depend on the interaction of the
universities and the industry served the
established ones the emerging ones the
expiring ones the intellectual
interactions above all surely the
question of what makes chemical
engineering tick is interesting too
chemical engineers and when we know the
answer we ought to be able to steer the
discipline toward its next centennial
convocation thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much skip for an
extremely interesting presentation next
we have a bit of a treat especially for
some of our older alumni because we're
gonna have two of our professors emeriti
who were here in the 1920s at a time of
great activity tell tell us their
personal reflections on those early days
first we'll hear from professor Hoyt
huddle who entered the the Institute
just a year or two after the department
was formed Hoyt
skip what you said makes me feel that
what I have to say is unimportant my
thinking back to the early 20s when I
decided to become a chemical engineer
triggered such a flood of memories that
my choice of what to cover was difficult
I have chosen the exciting decade of the
twenties that was the period in which
MIT was at a low ebb but finally started
on a dramatic rise under Karl Compton
the period in which chemical engineering
was outstanding among mi t--'s
departments and set the pattern of high
competence which it has maintained since
then the period that embraces water and
Warren K Lewis's headship and a period
about which I can speak mostly firsthand
because I arrived here for graduate
study in 1922 I shall describe
engineering at MIT in the 20s then four
of the extraordinary chemical engineers
responsible for that early picture mi
t--'s department of chemistry was so
overloaded with students in the chemical
engineering option by 1920 that chemical
engineering as dr. the Scriven has told
you was made a separate department that
year may I have the first slide please
there the first slide please there are
many ways to measure department quality
the doctors degree was not common among
engineers in 1920 but the number of such
degrees granted is one measure perhaps
not the best of department leadership
and change this figure shows the growth
of the doctorate program in mi t--'s
engineering departments and the
leadership of chemical engineering in a
ten-year period 39 doctors degrees in
course 10 versus 3 or 4 for each of five
other engineer
departments the science departments on
the right were in large measure service
departments for engineering students
only chemistry was serious about the
importance of the doctorate some measure
of the contrast between chemical
engineering and other departments at
that time in my student days chemical
engineers took a lab course in
mechanical engineering involving
primarily the testing of engines and
pumps and taught on a recipe basis we
also took our thermo in the mechanical
engineering department taught by the
department head professor Edward Miller
the only fluids were steam and air no
chemical reactions and time was spent on
diagrams showing how to fix the opening
time of steam engine DeVos but the
valves had stopped being built about a
decade before that D valve engines
I remember one class in which after
instruction on isentropic expansion of
steam in a cylinder a student said
professor Miller what is entropy
Miller's reply well it's what you used
to find the exit condition of your steam
if you go down this straight line he
never answered the question sometime in
the 20s our department decided to teach
our own thermal and we also replaced the
engine lab course by a chem engineering
lab other measures of low ebb the head
of civil engineering said in the 20s
that the doctor's degree was a waste of
time for engineers the head of physics
was a specialist in thermal conductivity
of refractories the only infrared
spectrometer in the whole of MIT was one
designed by me and built by a master's
thesis student named Ravel to measure
the radiation characteristics of fabric
it was later borrowed by professor
Harris in the chemistry department to
study the structure of benzene today's
chemistry and physics departments find
my story
hard to believe back to the good side of
the 20s the chemical engineering
department nurtured ideas that affected
other departments and lost my place
the first of two SCD theses in chemical
engineering those of John Keats and
Charlie hurty were on ferrous metallurgy
Louis's contacts with Bethlehem Steel
through our practice school stationed at
Lackawanna made him think that George
Waterhouse an english metallurgist at
the steel plant could fill a blind spot
in the metallurgy Department
so Waterhouse was made a professor in
metallurgy nuclear engineering started
in chemical engineering and when it
became a separate department we lost
four men all distinguished in their
later careers the department of food
technology for some years used walker
los McAdams and Gilliland with problems
recast to fit the new kind of interest
Phil and gas engineering was spawned by
Haslem and Chemical Engineering in 1925
and went back into the department in
1932 I had been against what separation
in the first place on on men on men and
now this is most of what I have to say
the chemical engineers in the chemistry
department before 1920 before the 1920
split included some very strong
characters outspoken argumentative Abel
self-confidence and I'll spend the rest
of my time on four of them Walker Louis
Wilson and Haslem may I have the next
slide I despair of evoking in you the
reactions to these men of the chemical
engineers who knew them in the 20s most
of you relative old-timers knew only one
of those four Louis but William H Walker
Lois's was it was the Lewises idol and
that word is not an exaggeration
look I had a PhD from getting he was
head of the engineering option in
chemistry from 1910 until he left MIT
Walker was poised gentlemanly absolute
master of the English language and
strong in his convictions so strong this
to get himself in trouble
Louis was a much better chemical
engineer but in the 20s he was by
comparison with Walker an awkward
country boy he said so himself but the
two were alike in the high intensity of
their reaction to life's stimuli the
growth of their mutual respect shows in
a story about Lewis's early days as a
research assistant a student felt him
properly that he'd been unfairly accused
of cheating by young Louis and went with
his story to the department head dr.
Talbot goatee bearded pompous Talbot
called Walker in and asked for an
explanation
Walker defended Louis with his customary
intensity and abruptness saying the
student hasn't had leg to stand on and
left then he went to Louis and said
Louis what the hell have you been up to
now
Walker founded the research laboratory
of applied chemistry r-la c2o course
tenman in 1985 years after the
distinguished physical chemist Arthur
noise founded the research lab of
physical chemistry two very able men
each so strong in his views as to have
near contempt for those of the other
Walker's own words and I quote science
by itself produces a very badly deformed
man who becomes rounded out to a useful
creative being only with great
difficulty noise was equally disparaging
in his comments on the value of teaching
engineering both had excellent
objectives both went too far but RL AC
in the 20s was an excellent a great
success an important addition to
chemical engineering teaching to save
time I have to skip some but it
multiplied the friction between Moi's
and Walker until each left MIT noise in
1919 into California to help convert
through college into Caltech Walker in
1922 go back into consulting work
Walker's large contributions to Chemical
Engineering included included his
development with little of the unit
operations of chemical engineering
concept his contributions to the course
ten Bible principles of chemical
engineering
he insisted on clarity of expression and
rewrote or demanded rewrite of
significant parts of that book the next
slide please
I could not find this picture of the man
I want to focus on next Wilson with the
red mark under him but time doesn't let
me talk about the others that you
recognize Mack on the left the
conscience of the department in telling
an engineer what to bet on Haslam Louis
Wilson and Robbie the man who wrote the
textbook we heard about and in the
second row on the left is Walter Whitman
and on the extreme right Dan Barnard I
don't know the others but I knew though
those seven Oh
when Walker left RL AC Robert E Wilson
became director Wilson had been a
boyhood friend of Carol Compton growing
up in the same town he had graduated
from MIT in 1915 and had become a major
in the chemical Corps in World War one
Wilson was a fast thinker and hard
driver he doubled our la C's industrial
contracts expanded its staff to over 30
and was responsible for many papers
being published
he enjoyed arguing with Lewis he noticed
that Louis had a technique of forming or
of unearthing a technical statement that
was true but at first thought appeared
Rome and of presenting it bombastically
to start an argument so Wilson played
the same game in the spring Louis would
receive a photostat copy of a page out
of Wilson Internal Revenue return
including such a statement as three
dollars received from wk Lewis and
dollar to donut bets
in 1921 Wilson left MIT to become at age
28 director of research of Standard Oil
of Indiana Robert T Haslam followed
Wilson Asst director of our La si the
next year Walter Whitman became the
assistant director under Haslam and two
years later followed Wilson in the
Standard Oil of Indiana Witt told me
this story about his two bosses
shortly before Wilson left MIT Louis
Wilson Haslem and Whitman had lunched
together at Waltons restaurant on mass
Avenue where the Stratton Student Center
now stands as they walked back to
building two Wilson and Lewis in front
and Haslem and Whitman be behind Wilson
suggested to Lewis that the issue by the
Department of a memorial volume of our
La si publications under Wilson's
stewardship would be appropriately Louis
managed to sidestep and Wilson kept on
saying that our La si would probably
never publish as many papers in one year
as it had during the past year under him
Whitman and Haslam where of course
listening and Haslem gritted his teeth
and murmured DeWitt the research
laboratory of applied chemistry will
publish small papers in this coming year
than last
if I have to copy them out of the
Encyclopedia Britannica
the story the story measures both men
I had an enormous respect and warm
feeling for the Wilson I got to know
Lear's later he'd lost some of that
egotism I think by then we were together
at a technical meeting at White Sulphur
Springs Virginia in 1935 Wilson was by
then standard president of standard of
umbrella of Indiana at the day's
technical meeting he vigorously joined
in the discussion of papers an activity
similar to his well-known performance at
ACS meetings he had a national
reputation for that that evening the two
of us took a long walk together and I
said dr. Wilson I can't understand how
you find time to run standard of Indiana
and come to these technical meetings and
participate with such obvious enthusiasm
his reply well I have to have some way
to relax Wilson moved from presidency to
chairman of the board and then became a
member of the Atomic Energy Commission
as I've said Haslam took over from with
Wilson Haslam after graduating from MIT
in 1911 had taken a position with Union
carbon company and with in a year the
men who had employed him was working
under him having returned after World
War one to MIT to head up the practice
school Haslam was happy to add direction
of our la sea to his activities I'm
going to insert something here that's
not part of my story one of next slide
the next slide please
that's Tom Sherwood and be honest on the
afternoon in
south velour main 60-second exposure and
to stop it I threw my cap over the
camera lens that's as much as I'll have
time to give you on the practice school
where am I
Haslem us are happy to add direction of
our lazy to his activities he increased
the size of the staff the slide off
police he published many papers
some of them positively not meriting
publication found time to write a book
fills and their combustion with russell
set up a course in fuel and gas
engineering separate from chemical
engineering went with russell to germany
to arrange cross-licensing of
hydrogenation called virgin ization of
heavy oil and brown coal between
Standard Oil of New Jerseyan EJ Farben
and the US and 1927 thought it was
running out of oil and in 1928 left MIT
to become manager of Standard Oil
Development Company now Exxon research
from engineering he was senior vice
president of the world's largest
corporation Standard Oil of New Jersey
when he retired going into W our grace
I've described three of the four strong
characters that I mentioned earlier the
next slide please
Lewis is left a product of Walker
Justice hesselman law and Wilson were
products of Lewis dr. all of us in
coerced him I disagreed with doc on some
points of principle and a few in the
area of ethics but I've known no one
well who has stimulated me more taught
me to admire straight thinking and try
to achieve it more
or whose sense of fairness of true
concern over the problems of society
politics and conduct I consider to have
been as well developed as ducks
discussions bonus sermons were frequent
sometimes a bombastic but always
impressively organized and Doc's
capacity to stretch a few facts to
retreat valuable new conclusions and his
impressive memory sometimes shamed me I
once asked a question which showed
ignorance of the basis for what seemed
an ingenious technical argument his
reply why huddle don't you remember you
showed me that several months ago the
next slide please
I will I'll have to skip four never told
and I think whether good stories of
Louis to gain time to emphasize his
capacity to teach how to think straight
industrial stoichiometry was his best
test vehicle and he so sold me on it as
a tool for teaching straight thinking
that in my graduate class in combustion
I took the first two days of a term to
review combustion Stoke but to show the
new graduate students that reviewing
undergraduate Stoke was not an insult to
them I gave for several years a
ten-minute written quiz at the very
beginning of the first class of the term
but to answer that quiz you who've been
exposed to Lewis don't need pencil or
paper or slide rule or calculator and
you don't need ten minutes you just need
to look at the ceiling and think a la
Louis
for one minute here it is methane is
burned completely in a furnace the stack
gas of which analyzes ten and a half
percent co2 or set what percent excess
air has been used